um when Mike Nichols was casting the
London company of dark Symons barefoot
in the park he chose an unknown who's
gone on to stardom most recently in the
forthcoming movie thieves and that girl
is Marlo Thomas and with her one of the
best-selling writers of vers in American
history and twice nominated for Academy
Awards for his way with words and music
the Peripatetic poet what kind of poet
peripatetic thank God they gave that
line peripatetic Rod McKuen come on
golden
[Music]
the nominees for the best original
dramatic score are Gerald freed for
birds do it bees do it
Alex North for bite the bullet John
Williams for jaws and Jack netsy for One
Flew Over the Cuckoo's Nest Jerry
Goldsmith to the wind and the lion and
the winner is John Williams the jar
dick zanuck and David Brown thank you
both for giving me the opportunity to
work with an extraordinary man Steven
Spielberg the great Universal orchestra
my friend herb Spencer thank you and all
the members of this Academy for giving
me this honor I'm a grateful man thank
you very much
[Applause]
[Music]